et à partir du mois de juin prochain il
ne faudra plus que trois heures pour
relier paris à marseille en tgv contre
4h15 aujourd'hui les premiers essais à
plus de 350 km ont eu lieu aujourd'hui
entre aix en provence et valence nos
envoyés spéciaux patrick esther et
benoît vers en était du voyage
adieu paris-nice un grand embouteillage
adieu la grande ville est heureuse la
méditerranée mais il ya 50 ans pour
gagner la méditerranée
il fallait plus de dix heures
actuellement le tgv met encore au moins
quatre heures et 15 minutes pour relier
marseille
roulant sur une voie ancienne après lyon
traversant à 90 km heure seulement les
gars comme valence ou avignon
mais bientôt ce temps de parcours va
s'effondrer 250 km de lignes nouvelles
ont été construits avec des rails posés
sur caoutchouc et calais avec des jouets
en plastique moins de vibrations donc
moins de bruit les rails poli à la meule
480 trois ouvrages d'art un chantier de
12 années de 25 milliards de francs qui
a permis aujourd'hui un premier tgv
laboratoire de rouler à 350 km heure
entre valence et aix en provence
un essai destiné à vérifier la qualité
du roulement de cette voie une vitesse
de 330 pour les essais suffirait pour
pour rouler à 300 par la suite là on a
pensé qu'on pouvait rouler jusqu'à 350
on le fait et effectivement ça se passe
très bien
le tests officieux du verre d'eau le
prouve c'est à peine s'ils vivent
reposer sur le volant du conducteur
pratiquement identique à une vitesse
commerciale à trois qui remettra
oui le 10 juin 140 tgv emprunteront
chaque jour cette ligne nouvelle
avec ces trois gars entièrement neuve
avignon valence aix-en-provence 23
millions de passagers attendus un défi
économique considérable
la sncf qui ont gagné 30 % de voyageurs
supplémentaires
la véritable bataille du rail va pouvoir
commencer parce qu'à cette vitesse là
avec trois heures entre paris et
marseille
quelles que soient les conditions
météorologiques le train va devenir un
concurrent redoutable pour l'avion